[Music]
hey I think this is yours
[Music]
most important thing keep your finger
off the trigger at all times unless you
need to shoot somebody when that happens
until you run dry
keep your eyes open every cop in the
country is gonna be looking for us
big Nick original gangster cop in the
flesh
watch italic for dead six on the way to
the hospital I check he's a bad guy
we're gonna make you a deal
give me the names of all the guys who
got away I'll get your medic thank you
no snitch
yo he's dying son we got a problem
it's a major crime get to know your
enemy boys every big-time crew has been
busted these are the guys who took them
down by magician you understand
sooner or later you'll need to fix you
could yeah Matt we're doing today the
plants we're trading up the federal
reserve's it's like Fort Knox at any one
time is anywhere between 500 and 800
billion dollars in there every
millimeter ever covered by cameras
sensors and motion detectors ten cross
streams stare at the building for two
minutes best security on your ass when
the bank that's never been robbed
[Music]
you know just means things I am a member
of a gang when we have badges which
means you are done look like the type to
arrest you know our cadets ego put you
in handcuffs drag it down to the station
we just shoot you
you're not the bad guys
we are like the house city girl I kiss
me
[Music]